[Música]
hola soy natalia cabrera y les doy la
bienvenida aquí a américa este es el
magazine de france 24 para revisar en
profundidad las noticias e historias de
nuestro continente y este es nuestro
recorrido de hoy
vamos primero a eeuu porque el
presidente joe biden centró su primer
balance de gestión ante el congreso en
la guerra en ucrania el mandatario dijo
que el presidente ruso va a pagar las
consecuencias de la invasión pero
descartó que vaya a enviar soldados a
terreno la decisión es entonces seguir
ahogando a través de sanciones al
trending
mientras la casa blanca condena de
manera enérgica en la invasión rusa
ucrania algunos países de nuestra región
optan por guardar silencio por sus
vínculos ideológicos y económicos con
moscú entre ellos precisamente los que
se destacan por sus prácticas
antidemocráticas como nicaragua cuba y
venezuela
y cambiamos de tema desde costa rica les
mostramos un proyecto de reinserción
social para los detenidos de un centro
penitenciario llamado own lock o abrir
puertas en inglés
y empezamos hablando de la guerra en
ucrania porque el presidente de eeuu joe
bailén dedicó gran parte de su primer
discurso del estado de la unión a hablar
al respecto en su alocución para rendir
cuentas de su gestión al congreso y a
los estadounidenses sobre su primer año
en la casa blanca llamada el presidente
ruso vladimir putin dictador pero
descartó que vaya a enviar soldados a
combatir en territorio ucraniano con la
condición de que el ejército ruso no
continúe expandiéndose hacia occidente
escuchemos
[Aplausos]
a nuestras fuerzas no van a entrar en un
conflicto con fuerzas rusas en ucrania
nuestras fuerzas no eran a europa a
combatir en ucrania sino a defender
nuestros aliados de la otan en el evento
que tú til decida seguir moviéndose
hacia occidente
pero aunque pueda ganar en el campo de
batalla pagará un precio bastante alto
en el largo plazo libra por libra
pulgada por pulgada el pueblo ucraniano
seguirá luchando por lo que tiene han
conocido 30 años de independencia y los
han vividos y esto ha demostrado que no
van a tolerar a nadie que intente
quitarle su país o hacerlo retroceder
ante un dictador ruso que invade a otro
país ha causado alrededor del mundo
mucho daño y me voy a asegurar que las
sanciones hagan blanco en la economía
rusa la decisión es entonces seguir
ahogando a través de sanciones a putin
ya su entorno mientras éste sigue su
ofensiva bélica y como parte de los
esfuerzos diplomáticos para disuadirlo
la asamblea general de la onu se reunió
de emergencia y apruebo una resolución
de condena
que le exigió a rus ya detener
inmediatamente las hostilidades aunque
no tiene vínculos jurídicos la condena
fue casi unánime y digo casi porque
varios países se abstuvieron o votaron
en contra entre ellos aquellos de
américa latina que tienen vínculos
económicos e ideológicos con el kremlin
les hablo de cuba nicaragua bolivia el
salvador y venezuela que aunque tiene su
voto suspendido respaldo a moscú y es
que miren entre 2006 y 2019 rusia le
prestó a cuba 2300 millones de dólares
para financiar proyectos energéticos y
de transporte así como para garantizar
el suministro de productos a la isla
según la agencia cubana de noticias
prensa latina
respecto a nicaragua rusia ha otorgado
también préstamos millonarios para la
ampliación del aeropuerto de managua y
ha donado autobuses para renovar el
transporte de la capital pero los
vínculos son en su mayoría en materia
militar rusia envía artillería que ya no
usa y en bolivia el ex presidente evo
morales tenía un vínculo muy estrecho
con su homólogo ruso vladimir putin y
muy lejano con la casa blanca y
suscribió con moscú numerosos acuerdos
de cooperación en material comercial de
energía y militar que fueron heredados
por el actual mandatario
luís arce
y venezuela no es una sorpresa vladimir
putin ha sido un aliado clave de nicolás
maduró y lo ha ayudado a mantenerse en
el poder a través de préstamos
millonarios ejercicios militares y hasta
donaciones de vacunas
en el caso del salvador rus ya no tiene
vínculos comerciales muy fuertes pero
según algunos sectores de la oposición
salvadoreños la decisión de abstenerse
de condenar la invasión a ucrania
refleja la misma falta de defensa de la
democracia por parte del presidente
nadie bukele cuya concentración del
poder preocupa a organismos defensores
de los derechos humanos
países como brasil y méxico pidieron una
salida negociada a la crisis sin
condenar directamente la invasión rusa
mientras que colombia chile y argentina
han pedido el cese inmediato de las
hostilidades
este último argentina estudia da refugio
a los ucranianos y es que allí viven
entre 450.000 y 500.000 personas de
origen ucraniano la díaz fuera de
argentina es la más grande de américa
latina y la séptima más grande del mundo
nuestro corresponsal en buenos aires-
natalio coso y conversó con algunos de
ellos sobre lo que está sucediendo
pirineo baluk y su esposa susana ruiz
siguen atentos las noticias de la guerra
en ucrania irineo no puede evitar el
recuerdo de su propia salida de ese país
sobre el final de la segunda guerra
material a que está el tactics muestra
orgulloso este tapiz que su abuela les
hizo poner a su familia en el carro para
viajar más cómodos y que aún conserva
justamente ahora cuando yo lo veo este y
me pone el lugar y se me mire se me se
me humedecen los ojos porque me pongo en
el lugar de ellos que ellos también
estaban yo tenía cinco años y ahora veo
también están a otros jóvenes que
también padecen lo que yo ya padecía y
por suerte lo pude superar y deseos de
que ellos también superen
para manifestar su rechazo a la guerra a
la comunidad ucraniana en argentina ya
realizó varias marchas en buenos aires
como esta frente a la embajada rusa en
la que estuvo irineo o esta otra en la
plaza de mayo en la que había algunos
ucranianos recientemente llegados al
país angustiados por lo que ocurre en su
tierra si antes estaba viviendo en
buenos aires ahora estoy viviendo en
internet
estoy viviendo en noticias en chats con
mi familia cada mañana y cada noche es
cómo estáis sabéis bien estáis bien y
cuando llevan horas sin contestar eso te
asusta
mientras tanto irineo y susana se reúnen
con sus hijos en su casa para compartir
novedades de sus parientes en ucrania
irineo y susana que es hija de
inmigrantes ucranianos son católicos de
rito oriental de la iglesia bizantina yo
como católico como creyente apoyo en la
oración que para mí viene
en la oración es importante por eso en
el fondo espero que
invite un milagro vote por el de la en
la comunidad ucraniana argentina cada
uno a su manera irineo y susana rezando
piden por el final de la guerra en la
que está sumida en su tierra ancestral
casas pasivas de luz gas y mientras
tanto compañías como facebook google
apple twitter y netflix están bajo
presión para que también tomen medidas
contra rusia sus ingresos pueden verse
afectados pero su credibilidad está en
juego les explicamos
desde el último iphone hasta el nuevo
reloj apolo estos productos ya no se
encuentran en rusia apple ha suspendido
sus ventas en el país así como sus
servicios de pago y de mapas
estamos profundamente preocupados por la
invasión rusa de ucrania y nos
solidarizamos con toda la gente que está
sufriendo como resultado de la violencia
la decisión se produce después de que el
ministro ucraniano de la transformación
digital le pidiera al consejero delegado
de apple tim cook que bloqueara las
ventas en rusia y apoyará las sanciones
los gigantes tecnológicos como apple
google y facebook dependen de las ventas
y de la publicidad pero también se
enorgullecen de defender la libertad de
expresión y los valores democráticos
esas empresas ya habían tomado medidas
contra los medios de comunicación
estatales rusos limitando su alcance en
europa y su capacidad de generar dinero
con los anuncios en respuesta a la
guerra de ucrania estamos pasando en
nuestras plataformas la monetización en
google de los medios de comunicación
rusos financiados por el estado
el director de spacex elon moscú también
respondió a la llamada del ministro
ucraniano los primeros terminales de
satélite starling prometidos por el
multimillonario para proporcionar
internet han llegado a kiev para ser
desplegados por todo el país mientras
tanto en rusia el kremlin presiona a las
empresas tecnológicas para que retiren
ciertos contenidos y también ha
restringido algunos accesos a facebook y
twitter
y cambiamos de tema y vamos a
centroamérica el gobierno de ciu mar a
castró en honduras declaró al país libre
de minería a cielo abierto es una
decisión polémica pues es celebrada por
los ambientalistas pero repudiada por el
sector de minas y energía con esta
resolución honduras se equipara con el
salvador y costa rica en políticas a
favor del medio ambiente mientras que
deja a guatemala solitaria en la
permisividad nuestro corresponsal andrés
suárez nos explica
de los tres países del triángulo norte
centroamericano honduras arrancó este
marzo 2022 como el segundo país en
declararse libre de minería a cielo
abierto ya lo había logrado el salvador
en 2017 con la ley de prohibición de
minería metálica y ahora se suma
honduras por cuenta de las políticas de
justicia climática de la nueva
presidenta xiomara castró él anunció
entonces obliga el cierre de por lo
menos 217 concesiones de minería y la
prohibición para expedir nuevas
licencias de explotación de suelos
mientras los ambientalistas celebran
esta decisión miles de empleados de
empresas mineras han salido a bloquear
las calles a modo de protesta por el
temor que tienen de perder sus empleos
esta decisión de honduras de declararse
país libre de minería a cielo abierto
deja entonces a guatemala rezagado en la
región en materia de legislación
ambiental tanto así que se encuentra el
estado guatemalteco actualmente
demandado ante la corte interamericana
de derechos humanos por el pleito entre
una mina suiza de níquel y 16
comunidades ya que la acusan tanto de
contaminar sus aguas como de invadir sus
tierras en costa rica el primer
emprendimiento para la reinserción
social de los detenidos es una línea de
accesorios llamada online que en inglés
significa abrir la cerradura nuestra
corresponsal sin de regidor nos cuenta
la historia
bryant mairena se dedica a confeccionar
carteras y otros productos con material
reciclado es un nuevo oficio que
aprendió en prisión tras ser condenado a
29 años por tentativa de homicidio con
otros 12 reos ha creado una marca que se
comercializa en el país saber que aunque
te equivocaste
pasemos la página y seguimos adelante
ahora de lo negativo pasemos a lo
positivo será hacia la sociedad personas
importantes colaboradoras
interesantes que en lugar de apretar
ayudemos que creamos espacios como este
a pesar de estar privados de libertad
esta iniciativa la primera de economía
social solidaria del sistema
penitenciario costarricense ha llegado
hasta la pasarela jefferson sentenciado
por secuestro extorsivo también es parte
del proyecto se ha especializado en
tendencias del mercado diseño e impacto
socioambiental para manejar el negocio
decidimos hacer nuestra propia empresa
con el fin de no solo lucrar de que sea
beneficio propio sino dejarle un legado
a nuestros compañeros para nueva
oportunidad fundación asesora del
proyecto lo más importante es que los
reos sean protagonistas de su propia
inserción social aportamos saliva
aportamos renta y esperamos próximamente
aportar el tejido social que esa es la
idea cambia la narrativa no venir a unas
personas a pedirles donaciones sino
decirles convierte suficiente convierte
señalado los productos están a la venta
en línea y en tiendas físicas
compitiendo con otras marcas de diseño
nacional a bryant y jefferson junto a
sus socios reos les entusiasma la buena
recepción que ha tenido la iniciativa y
sueñan con un crecimiento para ampliar
el emprendimiento inclusive a otros
centros penales
gracias por acompañarnos en esta emisión
de aquí américa en la producción estuvo
joan y agudelo pueden seguirme en redes
sociales en la dirección que ven en sus
pantallas y para más información de
nuestro continente sigan viendo france24
[Música]